добрый день дорогие друзья я продолжаю
рубрику вопросы ответы которые
накопились у меня в комментариях
связанные с этой ситуации и войной
россии с украиной это ситуация ударила
по всем нам практически не будет ни
одного человека который не пострадал бы
от этой ситуации особенно это сильно
ударит по бизнесу и бьет по бизнесу
поэтому я тоже пытаюсь внести свою лепту
и ответить на вопросы многих бизнесменов
как действовать в этой ситуации потому
что в моей жизни это не первый кризис в
моей жизни было очень много кризисов
различных и личных и
экономических и государственных кризисов
и баллистических и так далее конечно
военных кризисов еще не было но кризис и
в принципе все чем-то похожий поэтому я
продолжу отвечать на ваши вопросы итак
первый вопрос период спада экономики
акции некоторые компании сильно упали
многие люди полагают что сейчас самое
время покупать акции а что вы думаете по
этому поводу стоит и сейчас 70 лет
фондовый рынок нужно четко понять
фондового рынка разбирательств
американские западных фондов рынке
российский российский фондовый рынок
умер полностью его уже все не существует
он умер там ликвидности нет сердца как
только откроется бирже сразу вы видели
что творила с акциями
сбербанка он с двадцати двух долларов
упал на 1 цент то же самое будет с
акциями всех других российских компаний
поэтому ни каких инвестициях в
российские фондового рынка ближайшие
два-три года не может быть и речи в
принципе пока не будет ясности по
ситуации с украиной то что если говорить
про фондовом рынке америки как наиболее
ликвидные фондовые рынки то там та же
ситуация неоднозначная фрс сша сейчас
феврале и прекратил вливать деньги уже и
с мартом месяцем начнется цикл повышения
ставок есть это произойдет если будет
как в этом буду прогнозировать
четырехкратное повышение ставок там они
по 025 поднимает на 14 большие суммы
изымаются из экономики то фондовые рынки
однозначно будут падать будут падать по
всему миру потому что на самом деле рост
фондового рынка последних омска 5-7 лет
он ушел не за счет экономической силы
предприятия за счет печатанием много
пустых денег foresight сша федеральным
резервным банком сша поэтому вот этот
пузырь весь сдуется я считаю на фондовом
рынке что российском что в американском
сейчас делать нечего это крайне крайне
опасные места 2 просто существует ли
выгодные инвестиции в кризис а что стоит
инвестировать во время кризисов какие
отрасли посмотрим во времена кризиса не
существует выгодных инвестиций выгодные
инвестиции существует после того как
кризис да дошёл до своего дна вот на дне
и кризиса там существует выгодные
инвестиции но мы сейчас только в начале
кризиса обычно в среднем кризис длится
от полтора до 2 лет соответственно в
ближайшие полтора два года я не вижу что
появятся какие-то интересные и выгодные
инвестиции говорите какие-то инвестиции
будут выглядеть привлекательными я сам
буквально сегодня отказался от 2
компаний которые мне предлагать с
хорошим дисконтом с хорошей ценой почти
50 процентов от того что они просили там
две недели назад но я отказался потому
что и это не конец истории дальше будет
падать еще больше то что ты сейчас
читаешь выгодной покупкой буквально
через месяц может оказаться что ты купил
очень очень дорого поэтому во время
спада во время спада не существует
выгодных инвестиций чтобы вы не купили
из-за того что идет общий спад через
какое-то время это будет уже не выгодно
потому что такие же активы будут стоить
еще дешевле третий вопрос вы часто
говорите что вас имеется антикризисный
портфель что значит антикризисным
портфель и что входит в этот портфель но
смотрите антикризисный портфель я так
условно называю портфель тех акции или
компании которые обычно растут во
времена кризиса я из своего опыта знаю
просто существует такая пирамида того
отчего люди отказываются последнюю
очередь так вот люди в последнюю очередь
отказывается от продуктов питания
базовых продуктов питания перед этим
стоят это медицинские услуги перед этим
стоят обучения детей вот если брать тов
постов последнюю очередь не отказывается
соответственно если вы производите
базовые медицинские услуги либо базовые
медицинские препараты то это скорее
всего будет антикризисной в моем случае
я является акционером двух школ средней
школы это тоже я считаю эти кризисы
инвестиции потому что времена кризисов
люди не перестают обучать своих детей то
есть обучение продолжается я сейчас
буквально я эти дни наблюдаю большой
наплыв со стороны россии и украины ко
мне уже обращаюсь много людей с просьбой
устроить их детей в нашей школы то есть
спрос увеличивается даже во времена
кризиса хорошо себя ведет куриное мясо
из своего опыта скажу куриное мясо
потому что когда люди начинают беднеть
получается люди начинают меч и есть
конину говядину баранину потому что они
очень дорогие и начинают переходить на
самое дешевое мясо самый дешевый мясо
покоится то же время из-за перегретых
фондовых рынков в час кукуруза соя
пшеница
на самых высших точках то есть
себестоимость куриного мяса сейчас на
максимуме и вот когда происходит кризис
обычно вот такие все биржевые товары
падают себестоимость падает стоимость
курицами более-менее стоит и в
результате она становится более прибыли
чем период роста поэтому я называю это
антикризисный инвестиций если ещё учесть
тому что казахстан обеспечиваете себя
только на 53 процента куриным мясом 47
процентов импорта то импорт сейчас будет
дорожать ну за исключением только
российского потому что россия
девальвирует свою рубль то это тоже я
отношу к антикризисном портфель то есть
антихрист и портфеля это те компании
идти акции которые имеют тенденцию либо
расти во время кризиса либо как минимум
сохранять свои позиции во время фреза
если вы подумаете вы тоже можете найти
очень много таких вещей которые в
принципе ведут себя во времена кризиса
очень даже хорошо четвертый вопрос
держать деньги в кэше это хороший
вариант чтобы избежать потерь во время
кризисов но я бы сказал так держать
деньги в кэше это очень хороший вариант
время кризиса самый лучший вариант
конечно поселить в antichrist накопила
на втором месте это держать деньги в
кэше на третьем месте это держать деньги
в золоте а вы че уж золотых
коллекционных монет а ну в конечно при
этом когда мы говорим про кэш я имею
ввиду только валюта вот такая
последовательность той самой лучшей это
держать в антикризисном активе потом
кэша в валюты потом в золоте или в
коллекционном в коллекционных монет ах
ну а дальше уже идет в товаре этом и так
далее тогда и держать национальные
валюты в банке это практически на
последнем месте с 5 вопрос криптовалюта
во время кризиса стоит ли приобретать
ждать ли роста цен на криптовалюту но
смотрите криптовалюта сейчас пользуется
спросом она последний месяц буквально
припала но опять до последней неделю-две
выросла в цене потому что огромное
количество россиян но и вообще и
украинцев они начали покупать
криптовалюту чтобы вывести свою валюту
за рубеж минуя регуляцию центр
центральных банков поэтому край этого
лета в этом плане хорошо себя показал но
не вся криптовалюта это не bitcoin имеет
и риумы это так называемый стаи был
койны ю с д т ю д б этап то есть это ты
был coin на койны ели криптовалюта на
блокчейне привязанная к курсу доллара
или к курсу евро а не то есть
самостоятельно вот так у них цена не
бегает их цена жестко привязана курсов
доллара и курсу евро да по сути зеркала
доллара и евро россияне часто украинцы
очень много скупает для того чтобы мину
и центробанк это вывести свои деньги за
рубеж потом они выезжают со стороны и
уже в стране пребывания обратно
конвертирует криптовалюту могут положить
небольшие на счет либо обналичить
перевести так называемые фиатные деньги
поэтому криптовалюта во время кризиса
она выполняет больше атакую
транзакционному функцию то есть перевода
своих денег минует центробанк за рубеж
потому что в россии внедрили сейчас
ограничения на вывоз валюты официального
их деньги уже перевести не можете
поэтому люди покупают в крипто валюты
приводит в виде криптовалют я не советую
криптовалюты как способ сбережения
крытого и не советую криптовалюты как
способы инвестирования
я советую криптовалюты только для вот
этих целей то есть держите определенное
количество своих денег в криптовалюте на
случай если вам нужно будет уехать за
границу экстренно либо на случай если вы
решите уехать на пмж в другую страну то
есть крипто валюту можно использовать
как средство вывести свою валюту
ну я всякие регуляции и контроль со
стороны государства
вот только для этих целей но не как
инвестиции и нет а не как способ держать
там просто деньги вот для этих целей
моего крипто в отношении криптовалюта
биткойн uid и риму не изменилось я
считаю что если фондовый рынок сша
упадет фрс будет поднимать ставку то
криптовалюты тоже все упадут за
исключением с той был койнов stay был
койны это вот эти которые я сказал
которые являются зеркалом евро и
долларов их цена она параллельно растет
и падает вместе с курсом евро и доллары
то есть они жестко привязаны к курсу
евро и доллара то же время нужно
учитывать что
сейчас многие бирже криптовалютные
вводят ограничения для держателей
криптовалюты из россии они тоже понимают
плюс евросоюз я сказал что будет
создавать меры по недопущению
вывода капитала из россии через
криптовалюту поэтому это тоже инструмент
может быть ограниченного действия
особенно для россия для украинцев я не
думаю что будет какие-то ограничения ну
и да пока для казахстанцев тоже на этом
пока всё я заканчиваю вот эту серию
коротких роликов с вопросами и ответами
дальнейшем я буду продолжать по мере
развития событий по мере поступления
актуальных вопросов я понимаю что сейчас
время очень динамичная надо быстро
отвечать на вопросы из ситуация меняется
быстро приспосабливаться адаптироваться
плавно всегда помните что продолжайте
пилотировать чтобы не случилось
продолжайте пилотировать продолжайте
заниматься чем вы занимались в то же
время смотрите на 360 градусов по
сторонам не теряйте оптимизма и веры это
то что у вас выведет из этой ситуации и
всегда помните все когда-то кончается и
это плохое время тоже закончится и
как момент когда она закончится вы
должны максимально сохранить свои силы
для рывка вот тогда уже мы поговорим о
том как можно argo вот после кризиса